SEC chair Gary Gensler has been on the
war path against crypto for quite some
time but in the past 24 hours he brought
out the big guns aiming right at the
largest U.S crypto exchange coinbase
Shares are nosediving about 12 and a
third percent right now down 20 percent
over just the last two sessions the
stock action comes on the heels of
lawsuits filed against not just coinbase
but against the Cayman islands-based
binance exchange as well so regarding
coinbase the SEC alleges it's been
operating as an unregistered Securities
broker offering and selling securities
without registering those transactions
The Exchange firing back accusing the
SEC of weaponizing its office to harm
the American economy its Chief legal
officer saying quote the sec's Reliance
on an enforcement-only approach in the
absence of clear rules for the digital
asset industry is hurting America's
economic competitiveness and companies
like coinbase that have a demonstrated
commitment to come compliance the
solution is legislation that allows Fair
rules for the road to be developed
transparently and applied equally not
litigation The Exchange is also facing
scrutiny from a task force of 10 State
Regulators with New Jersey and Alabama
dropping their attacks right at the same
time alleging today that coinbase
violated State security laws as well so
the SEC filed a similar suit against
binance on Monday accusing the exchange
of violating Securities laws mishandling
customers funds and misleading investors
by co-mingling their funds with another
operation that the owner CZ actually
runs as well with gensler's intentions
for crypto becoming crystal clear now
could this be the final kill shot for
cryptocurrencies how can they survive
let's bring in one of bitcoin's biggest
bulls and early investors in the crypto
space pop Investments Anthony pompliano
pomp give me your give me your thoughts
on this your gut reaction to these
lawsuits
yeah Liz thank you so much for having me
I think there's a couple of key things
that people need to remember the first
is that in the United States of America
uh people are Presumed Innocent uh
before being proven guilty and so what
we're about to see here is a court is
going to hear arguments from both the
government and the regulators and then
from a business and ultimately I think
that the court is going to decide but
this is not a new debate we have seen
for years and years people across the
industry both inside of crypto outside
of crypto people in the legal profession
and people outside the legal profession
all trying to debate what is a security
do these assets meet that standard or
not now what is interesting about this
is we're going to get an answer here
right the courts are going to ultimately
hear out both arguments and they're
going to make a decision so there's
going to be Clarity for years I've said
to folks look yes we want regulatory
Clarity but do not confuse regulatory
Clarity with it actually being rules
that you may want so we may get clarity
but they may not be the rules that you
want and so be careful what you wish for
now the other thing that I'll call out
here is there's a difference between
centralized exchanges and decentralized
exchanges the decentralized exchanges
continue to be relatively on harmed
there's not really any regulatory
enforcement against them and they
continue to operate bull market bear
Market regardless of regulatory
environment one last thing I'll say is
there's offshore and onshore the crypto
analyst will Clemente from reflexivity
research recently put out a piece and he
talked about the fact that 86 of all
trading volume is outside of the United
States already now that's interesting
because regardless of what happens in
the United States whether these assets
are considered a security or not I do
not think that there's going to be any
impact on the International Adoption of
these assets and in fact if there is
actually abrasive action here in the
United States maybe what we will see is
an acceleration of adoption outside the
U.S as more people move offshore more
people start to adopt these assets
realizing that they truly are
international assets and not us-based
assets well what do you make pop of the
fact that most of the cryptos the majors
like Bitcoin and Litecoin and ethereum
are moving higher in fact when you look
at Bitcoin at this hour it looks like it
may very well overtake 27 000 again it's
at twenty six thousand
932 at the moment so the market
initially was shaken and now it's
stirring higher
yeah I don't really pay that much
attention to the day-to-day prices and
frankly I really just pay attention to
bitcoin more so than anything else in
the industry but what I can say is that
Bitcoin seems to be the asset that has
kind of passed all of the filters so
most of the regulatory organizations
around the world not just in the United
States all agree that Bitcoin is not a
security and therefore it isn't going to
run into any of that abrasive action
there's a lot of questions about these
other assets certain jurisdictions like
them certain jurisdictions don't like
them but what I do think that you see is
that any sort of asset that is outside
of uh kind of the Legacy Financial
system especially when it's
decentralized like Bitcoin it is going
to respond in a positive manner whenever
it is a clear line being drawn on the
sand there's centralized entities and
there's decentralized entities and
Bitcoin is the winner in the decision I
just want to say on your screen the SEC
is named these 13 tokens including
Solana and polygon as Securities not as
currencies so I mean we got to see how
they are establishing that
categorization right
yeah I I don't have that answer I don't
think anyone really has that answer and
so ultimately you know the regulatory
bodies they have a perspective the
companies projects and people in the
industry have a perspective and it looks
like we're gonna go to court we're going
to get an answer here and so we'll see
what happens uh you know what about the
ongoing Ripple SEC lawsuit of if we've
been waiting for some clarity on that
one the SEC originally took aim I
believe it was its very first attack on
crypto when it when it filed that
against xrp saying it was not a currency
but rather a security and do you foresee
any sort of clarity on that particular
lawsuit soon
yeah what usually happens in these
situations is uh when the SEC comes
forward with some sort of action uh
usually companies will either take one
of two paths they will either say yes uh
we are going to settle and we're going
to kind of choose a quick end to uh this
battle or they kind of dig their heels
in and they say look we're gonna go
fight this in court uh what appears to
be the strategy of uh kind of xrp Slash
Ripple whatever the entity that you want
to kind of describe there is that they
are choosing to go and and uh debate it
to go and present their case and so that
can take a long time right these
litigations can literally play out for
years and years and years uh that entity
has quite a bit of capital and and seems
to be a desire to uh to go and fight it
and so we'll see what happens yeah we're
looking at a one-week picture of xrp the
the intraday looks pretty interesting it
is now up but uh over the week it's
certainly off its one-way cause but it
is now trading at 52 cents when about a
year ago was more like 34. uh pump one
last yes or no answer here was this and
these two lawsuits by the SEC the kill
shot for crypto or no way
I don't think that anything anyone is
going to do is going to kill Bitcoin and
Bitcoin continues to be the king of this
entire industry and I don't see that
changing anytime soon Anthony pompliano
great to have you thank you so much
thank you